our goal is to make the best personal
computers in the world and to make
products we are proud to sell and would
recommend to our family and friends and
we want to do that at the lowest price
as we can but I have to tell you there's
some stuff in our industry that we
wouldn't be proud to ship that we
wouldn't be proud to recommend to our
family and friends and we can't do it we
just can't ship junk there are
thresholds that we can't cross because
of who we are but we want to make the
best personal computers in the industry
the difference is we don't offer
stripped-down lousy products we just
don't offer categories of products like
that but if you move those aside and
compare us with our competitors I think
we compare pretty favorably one of the
things I've always found is you've got
to start with the customer experience
and work backwards to the technology you
can't start with the technology and try
to figure out where you're gonna try to
sell it and I've made this mistake
probably more than anybody else in this
room and I got the scar tissue to prove
it and I know that it's the case and as
we have tried to come up with a strategy
and a vision for Apple it started with
what incredible benefits can we give to
the customer where can we take the
customer not not starting with let's sit
down with the engineers and and figure
out what awesome technology we have and
then how are we going to market that and
I think that's the right path to take
you just watched two amazing clips and
Steve Jobs take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you